depuis toujours les médecins et surtout
les chirurgiens ont essayé de rendre
leur boulot un peu moins pénible pour
leur patients en utilisant des
techniques pour calmer la douleur plus
ou moins artisanale et plus ou moins
efficace mais il y a une date importante
dans l'histoire de l'anesthésie c'est
1844 à cette époque Garden qui a un
ancien étudiant en médecine et apprentis
chimiste il fait le tour des États-Unis
pour présenter des shows avec le gaz
hilarant qu'il a mis au point un jour
dans le Connecticut un volontaire choisi
dans le public force un peu la dose et
se blesse gravement à une jambe mais
grâce au gaz il ne ressent aucune
douleur et il se trouve que dans le
public il y a un dentiste du coin qui
s'appelle Horace Wells qui FLIR le bon
coup et qui veut tester le gaz pour
faire des extractions dentaires et ça
marche du coup l'inventeur peaufine ça
trouvaille et elle est toujours utilisée
aujourd'hui sous le nom de protoxyde
d'azote alors pour être tout à fait
juste il faut quand même glisser un
petit mot sur Crawford longue qui est un
chirurgien qui aurait lui inventé
l'anesthésie allaitaire deux ans plus
tôt mais comme il en a parlé à personne
bah c'est un autre qui a récupéré ses
lauriers un petit peu plus tard